>> THAT IS TRUE!
MAN, WHAT A HAPPY WEDNESDAY,
EVERYBODY.
HERE WE ARE CONTRARY TO WHAT TH
DEMS PREDICTED, WE ARE STILL
HERE.
ON TWO DIFFERENT PLANETS.
BUT WE ARE STILL HERE FOR A
DEMOCRACY DID NOT DIE.
THEN AGAIN, NEITHER DID
STUPIDITY.
JUST LIKE MADONNA'S FACE.
BUT IF YOU'RE EVER WONDERING HO
THINGS WILL GO POLITICALLY, IT'
OFTEN LIKE JOE BIDEN TRYING TO
GET BACK INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE
YOU NEVER KNOW WHEN YOU'RE GOIN
TO END UP VERY IF IT READ TO
MOMMY MY LIKE WITH AN ENLARGED
PROSTATE, A VERY WEAK STREAM.
YOU PROBABLY DIDN'T NEED THAT
PART FOR THE OBVIOUS HOOP WAS
THAT THIS WILL BE A BLOW UP, BU
WAS A MIXED BAG.
WHAT IS IRONIC IS IN PLACE LIKE
MICHIGAN, PENNSYLVANIA, IN YOUR
CORP. DEMOCRATS WON, IT'S
DEMOCRATS THAT WILL SUFFER THE
MOST THEY VOTED FOR THEIR OWN
PUNISHMENT.
TRUE, IT SUCKS FOR ME LIVING IN
NEW YORK, BUT ONCE A KIDS ARE
ALL GROWN UP, I'M SO OUT OF YOUR
.
KIDS ARE WHAT I CALL MY QUADS.
THEY ARE BEAUTIFUL.
MAY BE IT WAS ABOUT ABORTION,
THEY GAVE YOUNG LIBERAL WOMEN
THE COLLEGE EDUCATION.
THAT SEEMS LIKE OTHER PEOPLE'S
PROBLEMS, MOST PEOPLE DON'T
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO GET
MURDERED UNTIL THEY ARE.
ABORTION, THEY ALWAYS WANT THAT
OPTION OPEN.
EVEN IF YOU THINK THAT'S MURDER
TOO.
THINK GOD FETUSES CAN'T VOTE.
STEPPED BACK AND YOU WILL SEE
SOMETHING OBVIOUS.
EVERYONE GOT SOMETHING THEY
WANTED AND EVERYONE LEFT LAST
NIGHT LITTLE DISAPPOINTED.
THAT IS DEMOCRACY.
ALSO HOW I'D DESCRIBE A NIGHT
HOT TUBBING WITH LARRY KUDLOW.
THERE IS GOOD NEWS FOR PEOPLE
WHO STILL CRAVE A GOOD BALANCE
OF POWER.
LIKE EVERY EX-WIFE, THE
REPUBLICANS ARE POISED TO TAKE
THE HOUSE.
NOT BY A HUGE MARGIN, BUT FACE
IT, BUT THAT'S BETTER THAN NOT
TAKING THE HOUSEBREAK WIN IS
STILL A WIN, BLOWOUT OR NO PLOT.
IT IS DISAPPOINTING, BUT IT'S
STILL A WIN FOR A DEFECT IS GIV
ME GET A SUPER BOWL RING IF YOU
WIN BIG OR JUST BARELY OR IF YO
DIVORCE TOM BRADY.
I'M BUMMED TO HAVE A DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNOR IN NEW YORK.
I WAS KIND OF HOPING TO MAKE IT
THROUGH 2023 WITHOUT GETTING
SHOT IN THE NECK BY NAKED
HOMELESS MAN SHOUTING SHOWTUNES.
IT'S TRUE, ALEC BALDWIN STILL
LIVES IN NEW YORK.
EVEN LOSING, LEE IS A HERO, HE
PUT CRIME FRONT AND CENTER AND
THAT FLIPPED SEVERAL HOUSE SEATS
.
THANKS TO HIM, EVERY NEW YORK
STATE COUNTY SHIFTED RIGHT.
HE GOT WITHIN 5 PERCENT OF
WINNING.
, ONE LAST TIME BY 25 PERCENT.
BE HAPPY AS LONG AS YOU HAVE TH
HOUSE.
EVEN BY A SINGLE VOTE, YOU STIL
NEED THE HOUSE TO INVESTIGATE
HUNTER TO HOLD THE PURSE BRINGS
INTO ONE DAY A OF GREG GUTFELD
TAKE.
I'M PLEASED THAT CHRIS TOO.
FATAL LAST, THAT IS TWO WORDS
THAT SEEM TO ALWAYS GO TOGETHER.
JUST LIKE AND SO DID STACY
ABRAMS,
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I SHOULD HAVE LED OFF WITH THIS.
SHE GOT SELECT LIKE AN ANTIQUE
DESK.
WHICH IS NICE PAYBACK FOR
ORIGINAL HYSTERIA THAT DROVE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
BUSINESSES OUT OF HER STATE.
WHO KNOWS, MAYBE SHE'S FINALLY
IN GEORGE'S REARVIEW MIRROR,
IT'S A WIDE ANGLE.
BOTH BETO AND STACY ARE FREE TO
DO SOMETHING OTHER THAN RUN FOR
OFFICE.
LIKE MAYBE WORK.
BETO, I HEAR THE GAP IN WACO IS
LOOKING FOR PEOPLE TO FULL
SWEATERS.
AND STACY, THE FALCON STILL NEE
AN OFFENSIVE TACKLE.
THAT WONT HAPPEN, THAT WON'T
HAPPEN, THEY HAD MSNBC
CONTRIBUTOR WRITTEN ALL OVER
THEM IN KORAN AND WHIPPED CREAM
RESPECTIVELY.
REPUBLICANS MADE INROADS AMONG
THE HISPANIC ABLATION THEY FLIP
MORE SEATS IN YORK THAN A
JANITOR IN A.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR TRUMP?
THE MEDIA SCREAMS THAT IT IS
PROOF'S TIME HAS COME AND GONE.
GETS BLAMED FOR EVERYTHING
ALTHOUGH AS THE PRESSURE CAN'T
STOP TALKING ABOUT HIM.
FETTERMAN FETTERMAN LOOKS LIKE
KEYWORDS, FURTHER PROOF THEY
WOULD VOTE FOR A GLASS OF WATER
EVEN A HALF-EMPTY ONE.
IN HIS DEFENSE, HIS BRAIN WASN'
WORKING AT THE TIME.
WE KNOW IN THE WORLD OF TEAM
SPORT POLITICS, HE IT IS
IRRELEVANT.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS HIDE IN
THIN WIN, AND LATER WE WILL PIC
UP A LOT OF STAIN REMOVER.
ALL AND ALL, AS THE RESULTS KEE
TRICKLING IN, UNLIKE WHAT THE
DEMS HAD THREATENED, LIFE GOES
ON JUST LIKE INFLATION,
DEMOCRACY ISN'T TRANSITORY AND
IT LIVES TO FIGHT ANOTHER DAY,
WHICH IS GOOD.
I'VE HATE TO SEE WHAT HE MIGHT
WEAR AT THE FUNERAL.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
TICKET LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUEST RATE HE TALKS SO FAST,
"OUTNUMBERED" COHOST EMILY
COMPAGNO.
>> HE AS HOLDING UP THE NUMBER
OF GOOD JOKES HE'S EVER MADE,
HOST OF FOX ACROSS AMERICA,
JIMMY VALE APPEARED TWITTER PAI
HER EIGHT BUCKS JUST TO GO AWAY
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
WHEN RESTAURANTS ASK HOW MANY
OUR IN YOUR PARTY, HE ANSWERS
YES.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK IN THE NWA
WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION, TYRUS
.
EMILY, FIRST OFF, HAPPY BIRTHDAY
I HOPE YOU ENJOY THE GIFT I GOT
YOU SOMEDAY.
I WAS DOING THE FIVE AND I WAS
JUST GETTING TIRED OF ALL THE
DOOM AND GLOOM.
EVERYBODY THE PEOPLE ON THE
RIGHT SET THEMSELVES UP FOR
SOMETHING IMPOSSIBLE, IN THE
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT DID THE RIGH
THING, THEY SET THEMSELVES UP
FOR SOMETHING SO DISMAL, THAT I
CAN'T BE THAT BAD.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SHOULD LIVE YOU
LIFE, WHAT SAY YOU COME UP
BIRTHDAY GIRL?
GET YOU KNOW I'M A FULL-BLOWN
OPTIMIST, BUT I BELIEVE THE
TRUTH THIS SUMMER IN THE MIDDLE
AND I LOVED HOW YOU PHRASED IT
BECAUSE WE HAD A SAYING IN
MOSCOW, ALL YOU NEEDED TO DO IS
PASS AND THEN YOU WOULD GET THA
DEGREE.
WHEN YOUR ATTORNEY WALKS IN, DO
YOU REALLY KNOW IF THEY GOT A C
OR AND A AN ACHE WHICH YOU
PROBABLY DON'T.
TO YOUR POINT, WHAT MATTERS IS
THE CONTROL OF THE HOUSE.
WHAT MATTERS IS THE CONTROL OF
THE SENATE.
THE PRIMARY EMPHASIS HE SAYS
WILL BE THE ECONOMY.
IT WILL ACTUALLY GRIND TO A HAL
PRESIDENT BINDS RIDICULOUS
POLICIES HE'S BEEN TRYING TO
READ TRICKLES A GREAT I THINK
THE GREATEST LESSON IS FLORIDA
WHICH FOR YEARS AGO, YOU THINK
ABOUT IT THAT RHONDA SANTOS,
HE'S 44 HE SQUEAKED THROUGH
WINNING THE GUBERNATORIAL RACE
AND NOW, HISTORICAL INROADS
INFORMALLY BLUE COUNTIES WITH
THE LATIN VOTES, HE IS ROLLING
UP HIS SLEEVES AND BEING A
LEADER ON POLICIES.
HE DIDN'T LIFT COVID RESTRICT
BUSINESSES, HE NEVER APOLOGIZED
FOR ANYTHING AND HE WAS ALWAYS
ON POINT WITH THE MESSAGING AND
WITH ACTION.
THAT IS WHAT WE NEED TO DO WITH
THE NEXT TWO YEARS IN IN 2024,
THE GLASS HALF-FULL.
GET THAT WAS BETTER THAN MY
MONOLOGUE.
JIMMY, I LOOK AT THE REPUBLICAN
PERFORMANCE LAST YEAR LIKE YOUR
SHIRT, IT'S UGLY, BUT IT SERVES
A PURPOSE.
GET A REALLY DO LOOK LIKE A FAT
MAGICIAN.
I THOUGHT IT LOOKED GOOD AND
THAT I THREW IT ON, I LOOK LIKE
DAVID COPPER FOOD.
I WANT TO APPLAUD YOU FOR BEING
IN SUCH A GOOD MOOD ON YOUR
PERIPHERAL BIRTHDAY.
IT'S LIKE RELAX YOUR 11.
>> AND YOU WERE 13, SO
EVERYTHING WAS GOOD.
BUT HE WAS 13.
>> THAT WAS THE LAST TIME HE HA
A GIRLFRIEND.
SAY SOMETHING ABOUT LAST NIGHT
THAT WE CAN KEEP.
I ACTUALLY THINK THAT WE ARE AL
BEING UNFAIR TO BETO.
IN SERIOUSNESS, NO ONE HAS DONE
MORE TO CLOTHE THE PEOPLE IN
THEIR OLD WORLD NATIONS IN BETO
FOR GOVERNOR COME BETO FOR
GOVERNOR, AND BETO FOR SENATE.
YOU REALLY THE HOTTEST FASHION
BRAND IN HONDURAS RIGHT NOW IS
BETO ANYTHING.
IN THAT REGARD, HE DESERVES OUR
RESPECT.
GET THE THING IS, THEY DON'T
MAKE THEM IN KID SIZES, SO YOU
WOULD HAVE TO HOLD OUT.
LIKE JIMMY GIVE ME FAT CAN YOU
GUYS ARE LIKE YEAH, FOR A SHORT
JOKE, HOW DARE YOU.
>> ARE YOU SURPRISED THAT
DEMOCRACY IS STILL STANDING?
GET I WAS GETTING READY FOR
ANARCHY THIS MORNING.
IS LIKE I DON'T THINK I HAVE TO
GET THE CAR TO GO TO WORK
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO TAKE OUT
THIS BLOG.
I CALLED MY FRIENDS.
I FORGOT TO CALL OFF TO OBADIAH.
I'M SURE IT'S NOT TOO BAD.
THE BIGGEST TAKE AWAY FROM LAST
NIGHT THAT I HAD WAS ONE, WE
NEED BRIDGE BUILDERS.
IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER WHAT
YOU'RE WEATHER YOU ARE
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT, IF YOU
LEAD AND YOU LEAD THE RIGHT WAY
PEOPLE WILL GATHER.
WE SAW IN FLUID OUT WITH RUBIO
INTO SANTOS, AS THEY LEAD, THEY
LEAD WELFARE THEIR STATES GOT
BETTER, PEOPLE LIKE SO MUCH OF
WHAT WAS GOING ON THERE, THEY
MOVED THERE.
USE AN ENTIRE STATE COME
TOGETHER.
IT WAS FLORIDA THING.
WE ALSO SAW THAT WITH CAMP AND
WE SAW THAT WITH ABBOTT'S.
THEY LEAD.
AND THEY LEAD FROM THE BEST
ENTRANCE OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
THINK EVERYBODY ELSE CAN TAKE A
LESSON FROM THAT BECAUSE MOST O
THIS ELECTION WAS BASED OFF OF
HERE, SO MUCH SO THEY WOULDN'T
EVEN DEBATE THE ISSUES.
WHY BOTHER?
WE WOULD JUST STICK WITH JANUAR
TAKING AWAY YOUR RIGHTS AND
DEMOCRACY ENDING FOR IT THEY AL
OF FIT TOGETHER NICE SO IF YOU
WERE A MODERATE DEMOCRAT HE WAS
THINKING I REALLY HATE THE CRIM
IN MY NEIGHBORHOOD, BUT I CAN'T
RISK ANARCHY.
EVERYONE HAS A STEAK THEIR TENTS
.
WE SEE WHAT YOU LEAD IN FLORIDA
AND GEORGIA AND IN TEXAS, AND
THAT IS WITH THE MODEL NEEDS TO
BE GOING FORWARD.
TO GET THIS GOING TO BE A RUNOF
BETWEEN I THINK WHAT'S HIS NAME.
>> RUNOFFS TYPICALLY FAVOR
REPUBLICANS, BUT THE FACT THAT
HERSCHEL WAS EVEN IN IT, HE HE
CAN SCORE TOUCHDOWNS, BUT I'M
NOT GOING TO HAVE HIM FILL OUT
ANY INFORMATION FOR ME.
>> AREN'T YOU HAPPY THAT WHEN H
IS TRULY HAPPY FROM LAST NIGHT.
THE DEMS ARE A LITTLE BIT
RELIEVED THAT YOU SAW JOE WAS
ACTUALLY JOE BIDEN WAS KIND OF
THRILLED, BUT IT'S LIKE THEY
STILL LOST THE HOUSE, BUT THEY
ARE RELIEVED THE REPUBLICANS AR
MAD, BUT THEY WON THE HOUSE,
ISN'T THAT KIND OF A GOOD
OUTCOME IF YOU ARE AN
MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD DECENT GUY
LIKE ME?
>> I WAS WITH YOU UNTIL THAT
LAST PART.
I FELT LIKE THE REPUBLICANS I
AGREE WITH A LOT OF WHAT TYRUS
SAID.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ELECTION
DENYING THING IN PARTICULAR,
IT'S NOT A GOOD STRATEGY FOR
BOTH SIDES BECAUSE OF THE ONE
HAND, IF YOUR SOMEONE WHO
DOESN'T BUY IT, THEN YOU'RE
GOING TO BE TURNED OFF FROM
VOTING FOR THOSE PEOPLE.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IF YOUR
SOMEBODY THAT DOES BELIEVE IT,
WHY WOULD YOU GO PARTICIPATE IN
THE ELECTION IF YOU THOUGHT IT
WASN'T REAL.
IN NOT GOING TO GET ANYBODY FOR
THAT.
I THINK IT COULD HAVE GONE
BETTER, IT COULD HAVE GONE WORSE
.
ALSO, THE ROE V WADE I AGREE
WITH YOU, LINDSEY GRAHAM, WHEN
HE SAID LET'S DO SOMETHING
FEDERALLY, WHAT HE PROPOSED IS
IN LINE WITH WHAT MOST PEOPLE
BELIEVE, HOWEVER IT MADE IT
HARDER FOR REPUBLICANS TO GO OU
THERE AND SAY LOOK, I JUST WANT
TO KEEP IT TO THE STATES.
HE SAID I WOULD LIKE TO PROPOSE
A FEDERAL RESTRICTION.
I THINK THEY MADE A LOT OF
MISTAKES THAT THEY CAN HOPEFULL
LEARN FR